this is directed to you professor thank
you for coming in I'd like to if you
could you expended more on your theory
you talking about secularization the
aspect of the market and if you take
Catholics out of the statistical
analysis than it works but if you put
Catholics back in it doesn't work I was
wondering why that is the case why is it
particularly Catholics that sort of mess
up this economic model that's being
proposed it well right at me that you
know that the problem is double first of
all kaathal Catholic countries do not
have typically free markets and religion
and yet they tend to be this is the
second point tend to be more observant
than products do at least if you look at
contemporary survey data and this turned
out to be true on a smaller scale within
the United States as well in the US you
also have the additional problem of Utah
another moment the Mormon wood stove we
don't fit this model terribly well
either and I think actually this anomaly
is relatively easy to account for in
terms of the kind of organizational
political model that I laid out which is
number one Catholics are the pioneers in
the development of missionary strategies
particularly through the use of various
kinds of preaching and teaching orders
this is one of the things which
Protestantism does away with and doesn't
really understand what its law they have
a much longer standing tradition of
various kinds of parachurch
organizations lay confraternities today
allottees other kinds of quasi religious
organizations like guilds which stands
serve as a kind of a platform or a
template during the 19th century for the
development of yet other forms of lei
lei Association and parents
organizations and the you know the one
thing which of course then becomes a
problem for Catholics is is to tend to
be this close relationship between
between church and state and so this is
one of this to the degree to which you
observe secularization within Catholic
countries that typically arises out if
this kind of political conflict between
lay Republicans and then increasingly
kind of confessional eyes Democratic
mass parties you know France is is the
one it is it the best European example
this but in turkey in a way is kind of
you know phone to pay I mean it's like
you know it's like the most it's even
work radical version of that same kind
of process of secular radical
republicanism